let's go next to our caller from the
three one four area code caller from
three one four what's your name where
are you calling from
hello David this is Alan and I am
calling from st. Charles Missouri what's
on your mind today Alan I was wondering
if the Hillary Clinton had been the
president how do you think this whole
covered 19 pandemic would have played
out in America it would still be a
pandemic but our response would have
been closer to what South Korea did than
what we have today so as an example
Hillary Clinton would not have become
president and in 2018 disbanded the
pandemic response team she wouldn't have
done that Hillary Clinton would not have
ignored the color coded 69 page pandemic
response PlayBook that the Obama
administration created after Ebola and
left behind Hillary Clinton would not
have had such administration turn over
that more than half of the people who
were briefed on pandemic response in
2017 by the Obama administration would
have already been fired or resigned as
is the case with the Trump
administration so can we say we would
have been South Korea with Hillary
Clinton as president of course not but
just on those three issues alone we
would have been far better suited to
deal with this than we are under Donald
Trump it's very easy you know to go to
try to rewrite history or to have these
alternative histories if this that the
other thing but there's no question that
on just those three points alone we
would have been so much better off with
Hillary Clinton running this than Donald
Trump and I also wanted to know do you
think in the long term after this has
passed that we will ever get back to the
point of having packed stadiums
and sold-out concerts with tens of
thousands of people you know I think we
will I think we will and part of the
reason why I think that is it it is
common that it always feels like things
will never go back to the way they were
and in some ways sometimes things don't
like things will always be a little
different but I believe it could take a
while but eventually we will get back to
that hopefully with more precautions
better functioning systems and more
preparedness to deal with this if it not
if but when it happens again kind of
like after 9/11 yes yes it felt like it
would you know flying was never going to
just be flying again and you know it it
is different we have the TSA now we
didn't before it's not the same but by
and large things do go back to mostly to
the way that that they were Allen thank
you so much for the call I so
appreciated and appreciate the
thoughtful question